nous on aime le voyage la nature et la
pêche on n'est pas des spécialistes
juste des amateurs ce qu'on adore c'est
à les pêcher notre poisson dans les
endroits les plus sauvages de la planète
la mort ici on le cuisine nous-même
grillé mariné ou cru et on ne se nourrit
que de ça
c'est un peu le goût d'ici
si on ne pêche pas on mange pas
sans oublier de goûter aux spécialités
locales ce qu'on aime aussi c'est faire
des rencontres partager des moments avec
les gens du pays et surtout se faire
plaisir c'est ça l'esprit globe pêcheur
et aujourd'hui c'est en Islande quand
vous emmène avec nous
[Musique]
espèce de désert pratiquement article
c'est ici que notre voyage commence
Arnaud
qui veut dire le lac des aigles en
Islande absolument le lac des aigles un
avetenshini c'est vraiment situé pour au
nord au
Nord c'est vraiment au milieu de nulle
part donc le chemin est fermé environ 8
mois sur 12 il a ouvert il y a trois
semaines ce qui est vraiment bien avec
cette histoire de globe pêcheurs c'est
que on va vraiment dans les plus beaux
endroits du monde et ça on peut vous le
garantir
après deux heures de piste dans un
paysage du bout du monde nous arrivons à
notre campement ah ça y est ça y est on
arrive
enfin à nos chalets
ça va être sympa
bon allez
le campement d'arna va teen shady ce
sont trois petits chalets de 9 mètres
carrés chacun un confort rudimentaire
c'est parfait pour nous
en autonomie totale c'est ça qui est
sympa c'est en autonomie totale
allez viens on va chercher le reste des
affaires
c'est un des enjeux des globes pêcheurs
c'est se nourrir avec le produit de sa
pêche alors ils détaille moi ce qu'il y
a on a ciboulette très important
citron extrêmement important ensuite
l'olive l'huile d'olive super super
importante et après le reste un peu de
poivre du sel alors du sel c'est du sel
d'ici c'est une espèce de fleur de sel
islandaise qui sublime et ensuite trois
tomates voilà quatre pommes de terre
alors voilà c'est pas c'est pas tout à
fait Koh-Lanta mais si on pêche pas on
va voir très faim
on va pêcher
on est pas bien là
le glacier là-bas pour nous
[Musique]
affaires ont vite à pêcher
au pied du glacier des lacs des torrents
des rivières des petits cours d'eau ici
le poisson sauvage est dans son élément
et nous aussi enfin presque
[Musique]
la préparation non alors ce qui est
juste un peu chiant je dois avouer avec
la pêche parfois c'est la c'est
l'équipement c'est la préparation c'est
voilà il y a toujours un truc qui va pas
il faut quand même penser à 1 milliard
de trucs et c'est pas tout à fait notre
style nous on a envie que ça aille très
vite non
à force on a fini par s'organiser à peu
près mais qu'est-ce qu'on a fait comme
effort pour s'organiser et qu'est-ce
qu'on continue à en faire
enfin bon en règle générale
le résultat est parfois au rendez-vous
parce qu'ici c'est quand même un point à
des endroits les plus poisseux de
l'Islande oui mais il y a pas de bois
non faut quand même aller chercher le
poisson on est parti pour combien de
temps qui nous a été une heure trois
heures cinq heures
[Musique]
sur les traces des truites là il y a les
deux là c'est ça bah oui là on le sait
qu'il y a les deux on peut même avoir du
saumon aussi non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors
c'est la première
[Musique]
bon déjà on est pas mort de faim ce soir
[Applaudissements]
pour Bertrand ça commence bien mais moi
j'ai un peu plus de mal
[Musique]
Bertrand
le rose lui Amiens je vais mettre une
cuillère où il y a un peu de rouge aussi
[Musique]
c'est absolument incroyable changer la
cuillère prenez coup de lancer premier
coup de lancer et voilà le rose marche
ici voilà c'est une truite fario c'est
incroyable quand même
en fait l'euro ça ressemble un peu au
ventre de l'article char donc évidemment
il a pris ça pour un album peut-être
plus facilement et justement à propos
d'artics char je n'en avais encore
jamais pris voilà le premier
rôle mon premier homme article il est
pas très gros et une vingtaine 25
peut-être mais c'est mon premier homme
l'article
alors c'est marrant de pêcher dans ces
petits canaux qu'on voit juste derrière
moi c'est un peu comme au golf c'est à
dire qu'il y a un vent qui latéral donc
il faut qu'on envoie en fait
pratiquement sur la berge et le vent
ramène voilà c'est un petit peu précis
et ici des petits canaux qui relient les
rivières et les lacs il y en a partout
trop étroit pour les gros poissons pas
du tout vous allez voir
alors en fait c'est marrant cette truite
là
c'est la sortie d'un petit ruisseau ça
s'ouvre un peu et donc en fait le gros
poisson attend puisqu'il y a un qui
Goulet attends visiblement que ça
charrie les poissons c'est un peu un
passage étroit donc obligé donc facile
d'attaque derrière une petite au calme
donc c'est pour ça qu'elle a une belle
taille
la fin de la journée et la brume tombe
d'un coup
[Musique]
pour une première journée c'est plutôt
une bonne nouvelle
[Musique]
mais en attendant de manger notre
poisson il faut rentrer au campement
et la difficile de retrouver notre
chemin on est un peu perdu et même notre
caméraman islandais John port n'en sait
pas beaucoup plus bon
plus compliqué là
on a pris ce chemin pour venir
on a marché à partir de là
c'est impossible de se repérer et du
brouillard ça se ressemble il faut qu'on
traverse une rivière
on n'est pas encore paumé mais bon il
faut qu'on fasse gaffe ça c'est le grand
lac mais ce grand lac il était pas plus
grand que ça non
le premier lac où on est arrivé tu veux
dire ce premier lac oui celui-là
5-6 heures donc ça fait quelques
distances
on a dit au début qu'on était au milieu
de nulle part difficile de se retrouver
au milieu de nulle part
allez on y va
on va donc y aller à l'instinct on
marche on marche et on ne sait toujours
pas où on est après une heure de marche
à l'aveugle enfin la délivrance
[Musique]
alléluia on a retrouvé l'arrivière à
traverser
la voiture n'est plus qu'à
10 minutes à pied Bertrand on est sauvé
[Musique]
arrivé au campement la brume c'est
miraculeusement dissipée le temps change
vite ici on va faire très simple très
simple huile d'olive
mais un peu dedans là ouais des aires
islandaise un petit peu derbissement
du citron la façon la plus simple de le
faire voilà
tac et un peu de poivre que j'ai
concassé
on laisse un peu d'air et on attend une
vingtaine de minutes
on ferme
tac
[Musique]
on est en plein été mais
ça se sent pas trop
attends je vérifie juste mais
normalement c'est bon
et ça
pêche
c'est un bon couteau pour la ciboulette
en plastique ou pas pour les autres
[Musique]
c'est comment
ça manque un tout petit peu de cru tu me
connais non non c'est parfait attends
regarde ça
enfin pour moi ça aurait été parfait un
peu plus cru
il est 3h du matin la nuit vient de
tomber une nuit assez claire qui en plus
ne va pas durer longtemps
[Musique]
alors que la nuit était bonne très bonne
faire autre chose
je viens faire du shopping bon moi je te
pose avec plein de monde
avec du bruit de la musique la musique
dans tous les magasins la musique dans
tous les restaurants
ce matin mission Arctic char l'ombre le
chevalier arctique la star des pays
froids un poisson sublime racé mais pas
simple à attraper et on va commencer au
pied de cette cascade en été l'article
char quitte les lacs pour rejoindre les
rivières et les torrents là où l'eau est
plus vive et plus froide
mais ce matin pas une touche
[Musique]
visiblement l'eau du lac est encore
froide suffisamment froide pour que les
articles reste tranquillement là-bas à
gauche
ici il se cache encore au fond des lacs
mais de l'autre côté de la vallée dans
cette belle et large rivière on sait
qu'on peut empêcher et des gros
[Musique]
c'est du lourd ouais et en voilà un avec
sa belle robe gris orangée
c'est
pas possible
il a cassé au dernier moment non c'est
pas cassé alors
c'est très fort
sans m'énerver je l'ai remonté doucement
du fil je l'ai laissé un peu repartir
j'ai laissé revenir je vais revenir
jusqu'à
au bord juste au bord de toucher en plus
mais pourtant tu t'es jeté dessus mais
bien sûr
les poissons mais cette fois ça n'a pas
suffi
la journée heureusement n'est pas perdue
pas un article char mais une belle
truite fario
[Musique]
elle est pas très grosse mais elle s'est
bien battue je pensais que j'avais plus
lourd
après avoir remonté la rivière pendant
plusieurs heures toujours rien pas la
peine d'assister nous décidons de
rentrer au campement ça tombe bien on a
un petit creux
[Musique]
au moins c'est sportif
mais avec du poisson il y a un but
du poisson
justement la prise du jour va donner
lieu à un magnifique carpaccio en
couleur
lever les filets là et en fait filer il
faut
pas s'arrêter quand on commence à couper
voilà
ok regarde la beauté du filet
je crois que c'est pas trop mal réussi
la couleur est quand même très jolie on
dirait souvent
c'est pas le même couleur quand même je
trouve
sinon c'est un peu le goût d'ici
[Musique]
comme les Italiens
on ne mange que ça nous donc si on ne
pêche pas on mange pas
[Applaudissements]
il est 8h du soir et comme ici la nuit
ne tombe jamais vraiment après
l'apéritif carpaccio direction une
rivière plus prometteuse qui prend sa
source dans le glacier
[Musique]
il y a deux copines là-bas elle n'arrête
pas de me relooker
pointer tes invités à dîner
ce qui est marrant c'est que les moutons
sa vie quasiment à l'état sauvage ici
les bergers
à partir du mois de avril ou mai et les
récupère au mois d'octobre
en attendant place à la pêche ce soir le
poisson est vorace et il est en forme
il a envie de prendre son dernier
poisson moi c'est terminé pour moi 4 cet
après-midi belle rivière assez
compliquée les poissons se battent à
chaque prise j'en ai raté au moins trois
là c'est une journée assez difficile on
a beaucoup marché
les conditions climatiques qui étaient
compliquées
[Musique]
l'intérêt c'est qu'il y a vraiment
aucune journée qui se ressemble des
comportements de truite différents ça
c'est rigolo ça moi je trouve que là
c'était pas forcément très grosse
c'était très très vivace
[Applaudissements]
je crois qu'il est vraiment l'heure de
rentrer parce qu'en plus il est tard ça
se voit pas là mais il est très tard
[Applaudissements]
là il est 10h du soir
[Musique]
après notre dîner filer et œuf de truite
marinée et les dernières pommes de terre
qu'il nous reste
séance couture et rafistolage notre
équipement de pêcheurs n'est plus
étanche
quelque chose qu'on répare nos bottes
étanches nos autres salopettes étanches
il suffit d'un mini mini mini trou pour
que l'eau rentre et puis alors là c'est
la
normalement l'idéal ça serait de le
mettre dans l'eau
mais là on va pas le faire on va pas le
faire ce serait de mettre voilà et ça
c'est le trou ça c'est le gros nageur
mais il y en a d'autres
tu retrouves le trou non
[Musique]
tout ça
et comme c'est sec et bien je vais
pouvoir coller
je vais te tartiner de colle
et coin c'est toujours ce qu'il y a de
plus chiant voilà comme ça
le lendemain matin réveil avec la
bouteille d'huile pas pour en bois
évidemment mais pour le matériel de
pêche qui a un peu souffert ces derniers
jours
c'est nickel bon c'est parfait ça couine
plus ça couine plus c'est bon ça
dernière journée à arnavatten il nous
manque un bel article char un peu comme
celui que j'ai pris l'autre jour mais
qui m'a
décroché juste devant donc on va revenir
au même endroit
et on va essayer tous les deux et là on
a tendance
[Musique]
tout de suite c'est pas au bout de 10
minutes on le prendra plus mission
article
exactement là et c'est sur un espace
très court peut-être une vingtaine de
mètres
on va faire ensemble
[Applaudissements]
cette fois-ci c'est Pascal qui fait
apparemment c'est un gros et il se bat
comme un diable
pourquoi le fil a cassé
je pense qu'on peut changer d'endroit
c'est terminé pour ici il
t'a remonté c'est compliqué parce
qu'effectivement les toilettes
c'est différent il faut y laisser un peu
il faut pas le remonter trop vite cela
dit moi j'ai remonté lentement la
dernière fois il a lâché
heureusement il y a pas de règles
l'artichard se fait désirer mais pas les
mouches qui peuvent pulluler en été
un peu plus haut sur la rivière
heureusement une belle compensation
cette superbe truite fario de 60 cm et
de 2 kg 3
[Musique]
comme les moutons ici aussi les chevaux
vivent à l'état sauvage pour cette
dernière journée arnavatten nous
décidons de nous promener et de nous
offrir un déjeuner 100% local
[Musique]
bon c'est l'heure du pique-nique petit
pique-nique bon montre-moi ta bouteille
d'eau là que tu as pris avec toi
une des meilleures os du monde
donc il faut en profiter et que
n'importe quel petit cours d'eau dès
qu'il y a une eau un peu courante l'eau
elle est 100% naturelle délicieuse
pleine de minéraux enfin c'est ce qu'on
dit en tout cas quand on la boit
[Applaudissements]
c'est prouvé l'eau islandaise est
vraiment l'une des plus pures au monde
grâce à la qualité de l'air mais surtout
grâce à la roche volcanique qui filtre
naturellement l'eau de source et lui
donne tous ces numéros
[Applaudissements]
ça fait un peu primitif ou non
c'est comment
délicieux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
que ça fasse pas ours non plus
la chair est dure encore parce que le
poisson il vient juste d'être pêcher la
chair est encore un peu dure il faut
toujours laisser reposer les chair
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
après cinq jours de pêche durant
lesquels nous nous sommes nourris de
notre poisson très bien nourri même nous
quittons notre petit chalet d'arnavatten
5 jours en immersion et en totale
autonomie dans cet exceptionnel nature
sauvage
[Musique]
mais le voyage développe pécheurs en
Islande est loin d'être terminée sur le
chemin qui nous amène à Reykjavik la
capitale du pays un petit bonheur nous
attend
premier indice c'est fumer de vapeur qui
sortent de terre mais nous ce qu'on
cherche c'est une source thermale d'eau
chaude une petite piscine naturelle
perdue dans la nature
il y en a forcément une dans le coin
mais ne comptez pas sur les islandais
qui gardent jalousement certains de
leurs secrets pour vous indiquer le
chemin mais nous sommes persévérant
[Musique]
revenir
[Applaudissements]
oh c'est joli toute la journée
[Musique]
ça tombe bien moi ça fait trois jours je
me lave pas parce qu'il y a pas d'eau
chaude
parce qu'il y a pas d'eau chaude au
chalet
[Musique]
sans les mains tu veux faire des
longueurs
ce soir à dîner dans une famille
islandaise burchouche on va faire un
dîner qui n'est absolument pas
politiquement correct à bouffer de la
baleine mais pire on fait quoi encore
peut-être du dauphin
disons un quota les Islandais peuvent
manger un peu de baleines un peu de
dauphin
peu de ses poissons que nous on pourrait
jamais
oser manger donc on va on va chez Victor
chez la famille de Victor notre ami
pêcheur guide et va nous faire découvrir
les recettes typiques
islandaise 100%
sa musique
[Musique]
sont rarement fermées à clé quasiment
jamais au courant
on retire ses chaussures aussi quand on
rentre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai hâte de savoir à mon avis c'est du
sauvage
on va le mettre dans le barbecue sur un
plat spécial en bois du Canada
c'est de la pêche légal et donc voilà
les prélèvements sur les stocks sont
censés être minimes clairement c'est de
la super qualité
succulent et la baleine ça se trouve
facilement la saison de la pêche c'est
du printemps à l'automne
et la viande est exclusivement destinée
au marché local
environ 18 baleines par an
ils sont lents que des parfums
[Musique]
quel genre d'assaisonnement tu as mis
dessus
c'est un secret oui et tu vas te régaler
c'est quoi le secret alors c'est un
pesto maison
vous mettez ça sur le saumon avec un
petit peu de poivre du poivre noir
sur le saumon
depuis quelques herbes aromatiques c'est
tout
et maintenant on va rajouter un peu de
sel
[Musique]
et voici le meilleur morceau de la
baleine 5 minutes sur le grill un pouce
[Musique]
c'est pas le steak de la mer je sais pas
comment on pourrait appeler ça parce que
c'est que de la merde
là c'est le meilleur des filets de bœuf
avec un air de d'aventure
le lendemain matin départ aux aurores
pour une pêche hors du commun
ça va être sublime là
c'est un bon habitat pour les poissons
alors ça dépend des like en terme de
profondeur ce qui va jouer sur la
température de l'eau sur ce qu'il a à
manger mais d'une manière générale ce
sont de bons lacs pour les sales mon
idée qui qui sont dedans ici et ils
vivent bien et grandissent bien et donc
ils ont de la nourriture en abondance
au fil des kilomètres le paysage se
transforme on se croirait sur une autre
planète on est au cœur de l'Islande
volcanique
attention si c'est limité à 30
tout de suite
on arrive au sommet c'est magnifique
nous arrivons à 1200 mètres d'altitude
il fait froid le vent souffle mieux vaut
s'équiper
on va s'équiper on va s'équiper
il y a à peine 3000 ans ce volcan était
encore en activité progressivement l'eau
a remplacé la lave
les gros fils que j'ai parce qu'il
paraît qu'il y a du lourd ici le lac est
peu profond 10 mètres à peine
cela qui est bourré de minéraux
aujourd'hui on y pêche des poissons au
goût inimitable
[Musique]
très important tout poisson en général
de l'huile de tout de suite on garde un
poisson
bien frais et après pour moi
ce qu'il mange
ou alors en fait on voit il y a beaucoup
de petits de petits escargots
bon on n'est pas énorme mais assez joli
quand même
[Musique]
en tout cas pour le repas de midi c'est
assuré un petit barbecue donc c'est sans
huile d'olive sans rien du tout nature
mais à mon avis la truite volcano bon
alors tu as eu quoi j'en ai fait une
en a fait une aussi
je suis allé au bout du lac ou le vent
pousser parce que la nourriture elle
pousse là-bas et en 5 minutes j'en ai
chopé deux
Bertrand j'ai faim
et on a fait deux amis parce que
[Musique]
à quelques kilomètres du cratère
d'autres lacs sont nés de bouleversement
géologique comme celui-ci d'après ce que
l'on sait il y a de l'article char dans
ce lac Pascal et Victor préfèrent
déjeuner d'abord
pas moi
mes poissons favoris
sa mort ici
on prend juste le mi-cuit du dessus ça
nous arrange parce que c'est meilleur et
que ça permet de pas attendre
franchement c'est parfait une blanche et
une saumonée et au goût on a rien mis
parce qu'on a rien donc c'est nature
pratiquement cru et ça dégoût
exceptionnels et différents une
différence dans l'alimentation celle-ci
là qui était bien plus foncée elle avait
uniquement des petites escargots dans
son ventre et celle-ci celle-ci se
nourrit beaucoup plus de petits poissons
et ça ça va expliquer leurs différences
à la fois de couleur extérieur et puis
aussi dans la chair
normalement je devrais le rejeter parce
qu'il est petit voilà mais en fait il y
a beaucoup beaucoup de petits articles
chers ici et il faut les il faut les
sortir du lac parce que sinon ils ont
pas de quoi ils ont pas de quoi se
nourrir donc même les petits il faut les
garder il faut les manger
regardez c'est regardez cette couleur
c'est absolument merveilleux
poisson magnifique
regardez ce gris argenté
[Musique]
tu as essayé ici là
de retour à Reykjavik le lendemain il y
a un endroit qu'il faut absolument
découvrir son marché et notamment les
trésors de son rayon alimentation
ça y est ça ouvre ça c'est le marché de
Reykjavik a ouvert le samedi et dimanche
et des trucs qu'on trouve une faille
l'agneau on ne le tue en octobre
tu as remarqué qu'on peut goûter le
je retiens
fermenté une spécialité islandaise
ça c'est fort premier goût c'est assez
fort
j'ai l'impression que je suis en train
de manger un requin qui qui s'est échoué
sur la sur la banquise depuis Simba
ce qui est bien avec Victor c'est qu'il
connaît son pays par cœur et donc c'est
drôle de coutume gustatives
c'est du cormoran l'oiseau noir tu vois
du cormoran
ça c'est de la viande de phoque
c'est bon le phoque ouais c'est pas mal
et pour ceux qui aiment l'omelette
article rien de mieux que des œufs de
guilmo un oiseau marin des pays
nordiques en début de saison on peut les
mec descendre encore de signer sur des
falaises descendent encore des pour
aller récupérer les deux
c'est sportif d'aller chercher les œufs
plus attendu le saumon du pays mais il
faut savoir le choisir
[Musique]
plus une grasse généralement moins il
sera bon
et justement puisque l'on parle de
saumon c'est le moment tant attendu ce
matin nous ne sommes pas allés bien loin
de Reykjavik nous sommes juste à la
sortie de la ville étonnant pour nous
qui ne péchons que dans les endroits
sauvages mais cette rivière est très
réputée
[Musique]
on avait des petits fils pour les pour
les pour les truites
jusqu'à 5 6 kg et là
minimum 7 kg et après jusqu'à 22 kg
comme les gens veulent quoi ça veut dire
qu'elle va se déchaîner
c'est plus puissant
c'est pas facile à faire ça
petit conseil supplémentaire évidemment
on l'est déjà un mètre de fil parce
qu'il est usé il a été déjà peut-être un
peu croqué par les poissons par les
truites
et donc là on prend aucun risque
c'est déjà descendu d'accord on va
pêcher la chute juste ici donc il va
falloir qu'on s'approche doucement
le saumon se pêche à la mouche ou au
vert le vert c'est la technique Ancestra
l'Islande alors c'est celle-là qu'on va
utiliser
[Musique]
donc là je vais poser mon vélo j'ai un
plan là de 20 g et faire dériver
gentiment en espérant qu'il y a un seul
mot qui l'attaque au début c'est Victor
qui nous montre la voie il pêche le
saumon depuis qu'il est tout petit il
connaît la rivière la technique
aujourd'hui nous sommes un peu ses
élèves
balancer et balancer
voilà et tu l'as magnifique
[Musique]
mais ta canne toujours haute pour cette
pêche il ne suffit pas de savoir où
mettre sa ligne il faut que le verre et
le plomb soit à la parfaite profondeur
et qu'il ne soit pas dévié par le
courant et surtout il faut comprendre où
se cache le saumon et enfin savoir le
ferrer encore plus compliqué
alors je l'ai vu j'ai une belle touche
tout à l'heure mais il suffit pas la
touche
et là je viens de casser c'est une
technique qui est compliqué
en plus on a pas trop l'habitude de
pêcher au vert c'est une façon assez
spéciale de faire son lancer
on n'est pas forcément le poids et le
plomb le plomb est pas forcément à la
bonne hauteur il faut vraiment connaître
pas simple mais amusant
[Musique]
nous remontons en amont de la rivière
déjà 8 heures que l'on pêche et à part
la touche de Bertrand toujours rien
[Musique]
aucun saumon à l'horizon aucune touche
jusqu'à ce que Victor change son appât
une mouche à la place du verre
à la fin de la dérive il est monté
technique parce que moi j'ai pas là tu
es content
c'est le premier de l'année pour moi
donc
mais nous on garde le verre plus adapté
à notre matériel
là le lancer et le positionnement de
Bertrand a été parfait mais cette fois
c'est son fils qui a lâché
pour Pascal toujours pas de touche mais
il a une botte secrète barzet le
meilleur pêcheur de saumon de la rivière
et les gens ils me dis que les ponts ils
sont pas assez bas et on connaît bien le
trou ok donc plus de verres de terre et
les plombs vraiment
[Musique]
alors c'est mon premier moitié saumon
puisque monsieur m'a aidé à attraper il
a fait rire j'ai les sorties tout de
même alors je vous présente mon nouvel
ami
voilà comment faire ça fait deux heures
que je suis sur le poste sur 3 mètres
carrés lui premier coup y faire et me
dit à toi l'honneur de sortir merci
beaucoup mon nouvel ami
premier lancer il a chopé
moi aussi je veux mon premier saumon et
grâce encore à barzet Jean Ferrat dans
la minute
malheureusement je casse encore
décidément ce n'est pas mon jour regarde
le film n'est pas bon
ce fil était pourtant neuf je suis
victime d'un défaut de fabrication
heureusement Victor n'a pas le même il
vient d'avoir une grosse touche le
combat commence
ce qui va le sortir il galère
mais s'il est bon il va le voir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avec un fil pas très gros je préférais
pas prendre du risque
57 62
une heure après chez Victor
[Musique]
ensemble enfin c'est toi qui l'a vu
est très bon pour ça
[Musique]
on a l'impression que c'est du thon
c'est parfait il y a plus qu'à déguster
assez facilement la chair
[Musique]
c'est comment
se termine
je termine bien on va dire
[Musique]
toujours bien de loin mais moi tout ça